NATO says Spain will become the latest
member state to send air defense systems
to Ukraine to help Kiev against Russia's
missile barrages earlier Germany said it
was dispatching a missile defense system
all this follows a two-day meeting of
NATO defense ministers in Brussels
or NATO Nations and Russia will also be
conducting military exercises next week
Secretary General Ian stoltenberg said
the Western Alliance would monitor
moscow's forces very closely
this exercise the Russian exercise is an
annual exercise it's uh it's an exercise
where they test and exercise their
nuclear forces we will monitor that as
we always do and of course we will
remain Vigilant not least in light of
the
veiled nuclear threats and the dangerous
nuclear rhetoric we have seen from the
Russian side
U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin spoke
after the NATO meeting he warned against
what he called Russia's nuclear saber
rattling
NATO poses no threat to Russia
and seeks no confrontation with Russia
but our defensive Alliance will as it
always has
protect every inch of NATO territory
NATO's preeminent task has not changed
to defend each and every Ally
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and America remains profoundly committed
to that task
and to our NATO allies
and to article 5.
Natasha Butler has more on the summit
from Brussels
well I think the mood at this NATO
defense Minister's meeting over the past
few days has been solemn and determined
we've heard over and again from the
chief of NATO net Yen stoltenberg as
well as the U.S defense secretary that
NATO allies are in it for the long haul
they're going to support Ukraine for as
long as it takes and that support really
takes the shape of stepped up weapons
deliveries to Kiev particularly those
air missile defense systems that Keith
says it's so desperately needs Russia's
Invasion though and its nuclear weapons
threats have certainly sharpened and
focused Minds here as in some NATO
member states are really looking at
their own territorial security and that
is why we also saw 14 member states sign
a joint agreement to jointly purchase a
missile defense systems to try and
ensure their own country's safety
because in the words of the German
defense minister we are living in
dangerous times